here we go from insider business insider
fauci says u.s still planning for covet
19 booster after eight months biden said
shots could be administered after five i
know some people who already got theirs
and it hasn't been eight months wow
there was a there was a tweet i saw
where they were like uh well now all the
data's screwed up
because we had like the regimen you know
two shots and then we'll track what
happens and now people are getting more
and look i i say it i say it all the
time
when there was a there's a report we
also have let me see if i can pull this
up this is from timcast.com switzerland
warns of potential terror attacks on
vaccination sites the swiss federal
intelligence service voiced its concern
with the national newspaper of the
weekend
that is horrifying if people go to their
trusted medical professional do some
research or whatever make a decision for
themselves and that means they want to
go get the vaccine they should be
allowed to do it nobody should be
stopping people from getting medicated
whatever that medication might be
because there are a lot of people who
are like you know that particular
antibiotic is bad for this reason it's
like dude mind your own business and so
when it comes to fouchy and and biden
another discussion around five months
you'll get a booster the problem is
not in my opinion the vaccine the
problem is the authoritarianism
that that is the problem with it yeah i
mean i i was vaccinated like the problem
is telling everybody what to do and
making making listen
i was just talking about okay i mean
we get to have decisions
i was talking to a lefty friend of mine
and i said you are supporting
a massive guaranteed no liability
contract for big pharma it's the
opposite of universal health care and if
this goes through you will never see
universal health care the other no
that's interesting the other thing too
is there
have been
you know any time anyone tries to make a
report about some concern with the
vaccine
um
that gets squashed by social media
instantly
so there's no way to have a public
conversation
uh because everyone's already everyone's
opinions have already been bought and
sold so you're not allowed to the rules
for instance here putin says no to
mandate uh vaccine mandates is this have
you guys confirmed this at all because
yeah yeah i saw you guys who's reporting
on it because i can't find any large
organization reporting on this i've got
we love trump.com
coronanews123.wordpress like who but
okay
what
talk about authoritarianism or the lack
thereof when the russian premier is
decided president as that's what he's
called they're not going to do mandates
if that's real
i think this all comes down it hinges on
do you think then they'd have to give it
away anyway so maybe that's probably
what it means well they don't they don't
uh properly they don't want to pay for
all those vaccines for their entire
population maybe that's a good point
yeah another another reason but it just
this entire thing hinges whether or not
these people are nazis whether blah is
like what's the threat level of cove
this story's actually pretty old uh i've
got something from this is funny it
didn't come up on google but it came up
on duckduckgo
putin says russia won't make covet
vaccines compulsory but skepticism
remains a problem for may 27th
interesting google search that i
couldn't find anything yeah this is from
a date and then i went on duck and it
popped right up okay maybe it's maybe
it's just a resurged uh article i know
he got the vaccine or maybe he said
something recently yeah isn't it crazy i
saw a comment where somebody i think was
on reddit where they were talking about
how uh you know emigrating to the united
states and wondering if now they
actually want to go back you know to to
russia
oh that's interesting yeah because of
what's happening in the united states is
is
it's absolutely insane dude i mean it
looks absolutely insane i hear the i
hear these stories from friends where
they're like watch this they're like oh
my friend texted me you know about like
being friends with you or you know or
like someone will say something like i
got i got a text from a friend where
they were like i can't believe you would
be friends with this person or that
person i can't believe you would watch
this show or that show you know or you
watch alex jones like how could you
watch or listen to dave rubin he's far
right you know
and i'm like you know what this reminds
me of reminds me of being a kid and
having people being like i can't believe
you turned away from the church i can't
believe it what's what's happened to you
and it's like
this this this level of dogmatic faith
and this emotional manipulation of
messaging someone and saying these
things i'm like yo these people are in a
cult well it's apostasy right because
you've committed apostasy that's what it
is here's the important thing
when someone would join a cult back in
the day you could take them away from
the cult and deprogram them but you had
to get them away from the cult you can't
do it anymore
you can't get it with their phone yeah
it's everywhere it's linked into their
minds well and now they're fed back that
same algorithm
so there's it's very hard to break away
from that you have to go to duckduckgo
yeah
even then when i searched putin vaccine
on duckduckgo i got putin gets
coronavirus vaccine from march well you
don't search for the title like putin
says no vaccine yeah no i mean yeah
you're right i'm not an expert with
searches um
search for the words search for that
we'll find that give me the words tim i
just searched for uh uh go putin vaccine
mandate
and then a bunch of stories popped up
putin says no compulsory vaccines yeah
rock i mean to be fair biden said no
compulsory vaccines from r2 well but he
lied well i got cnbc right here cool
well he
the government isn't uh like the federal
government isn't doing it bill de blasio
is doing it at the city level yeah and
all these other cities san jose is doing
it yeah and new orleans and san
francisco and they're all doing this
with the full backing of the federal
government biden goes out there and says
that he wants everybody to do this he
encourages
big companies to i think it was just
recently like the other day when uh when
the fda approved the vaccine was it like
a week ago
and he encouraged big companies to
require all their employees to get
vaccinated this is another really weird
thing that i've talked about before but
people keep emailing me claiming that
the vaccine the pfizer vaccine isn't fda
approved and they're using like it's the
weirdest thing a twisted semantic
argument that is not oh is this that's
the like other drug that has a different
name community which is literally the
exact same vaccine as per the fda letter
and so when bannon was here he mentioned
this and i was like uh i don't think
that's true and i googled it i'm like it
says right here it is the vaccine that
is approved and then i got a bunch of
emails like bannon is right tim take a
look at this and there are a bunch of
articles like you know patriot national
you know info or whatever and it says
something like take a look at this
letter and so i read the fda letter and
it literally says the formulation is
identical and interchangeable but one is
the marketing brand either can be used
because they're the same thing yeah what
he was saying i thought was that pfizer
has a bunch of different vaccines that
it's working on and only one of them has
been fda approved that's the community
one so when people say the pfizer
vaccine is fda approved they're they're
not being accurate because there's it's
one of the pfizer vaccines there's one
covet 19 pfizer vaccine it is being
marketed as community they are the same
exact vaccine under just different names
the fda letter says it is
commonly known as the pfizer bioentec
vaccine which will now be marketed as
community they are interchangeable and
the and an identical formulation
and so for some reason people are
claiming
you know they're actually two different
ones i'm like what do you what what yeah
is pfizer working on other covet
vaccines i don't know but i thought
that's what steve was saying no so
people keep emailing me this thinking
that there's some like underhanded
scheme to like trick people into
thinking that community is available but
it's not really that way they're not
liable and it's like no no just like did
you read it and so i just took a quote
from the letter and it says like these
are identical interchangeable and the
same exact formulation and i email it
back i'm like i don't know why you
thought that was true did you read the
letter right but people i think i think
it's because
when a lot of people said oh you know
i'm not going to get it until it's fda
approved right and that was their like
rationale and then once it got approved
they needed to maintain a rationale well
then that was biden's whole speech last
week was like all you people who were
waiting for it now it is i think just a
certain everyone just
get it if you if you really are like you
know
just just say it just publicly state how
you feel about it and don't rely on
semantic arguments right and maybe if
you don't want to get the vaccine or any
medical treatment then that's kind of up
to you it's up to you and i am not going
to give people medical advice when it
comes to like mandating it and whether
those people are nazis that want the
government to mandate this is like how
dangerous is covet that's what we have
to ask because when when people got
polio and were getting paralyzed they
didn't say it was authoritarian nazism
to mandate a vaccine they just did it
well maybe they did actually i wasn't
around my dad got it you know he took it
on the arm there were a lot of people
who didn't want to get it and also the
federal government at the time put out a
few different statements saying
you know
as people get this vaccine people are
going to die
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
from the vaccine people die anyway and
sometimes these things are going to be
um
you know coincidental this the cdc says
it very very bluntly they said it to me
in a statement as i interviewed people i
i actually interviewed one of the
highest guys at the cdc in like his full
military uniform a few years ago and
they said
we know there are side effects and
adverse effects we know that some people
face problems but it percentage-wise it
is substantially better that people get
vaccinated than not even with a side
effects basically they're saying the
needs of the money outweigh the needs of
the few or the risk from the vaccine is
substantially lower than the risk from
not getting it for society as a whole so
my thing is like i'm very much for the
individual i think you have to find
someone you trust
when it comes to uh medicine a medical
professional and come to a personal
decision that that i'm not going to make
for you i don't want to give you that's
even
what you were saying talking to that
cdhc official a few years ago
um that's even different than the
messaging we're getting now right no i
don't think so i think it's on their
website the cdc literally
okay yeah but from the mainstream media
from social media from like the way that
that message is interpreted
um that sounds very reasonable right the
way that that message is interpreted is
almost as though to say the american
public is too stupid to figure out what
literally said that yeah and so you know
the way it's interpreted is that people
are not trusted to make their own
decisions that's the problem right if
that was what we hear all the time and
people were like oh that's interesting
i'm going to make my own decision i'm
going to think about it but people are
told not to think about it to just do
whatever they're told and that's that's
the issue this is the problem that's why
i think we're always all collapsing
first we got the failure of afghanistan
the absolute chaos of the baby
administration donald trump was
anti-elected so people voted not for
biden they voted against
trump but it's like the most extreme
degree i've ever seen in my life you
have economic crisis labor shortages and
you have no
national unity and i don't mean just
like obviously there's a culture war i
mean quite literally a crisis happens
there's 15 days a slow to spread and
then instantly
every single grifter of grifters comes
out to make money the pharmaceutical
companies want no bid guaranteed no
liability contracts the government just
says fine then then all of these local
jurisdictions are like i don't care i
don't want to be held responsible so
whatever that guy says you do
all that's happening is people are
saying i want nothing to do with you
i want stuff for me like i said what
we're seeing is the elites
knowing that we hit an iceberg and
they're stealing all the silverware and
running to the safe to the safety boats
before anyone realizes what's happening
this was interesting too the other day
uh so we have a mayoral election going
on in new york city uh de blasio is
going to be out which is great eric
adams is the uh he won the democratic
primary in june he was the brooklyn
borough president um he's relatively
popular he was not the far left
candidate so people were just pleased
that he won that primary but anyway he's
running against curtis leewa
who
was recently doing a um
like you know doing a campaign event
that was interrupted by a homeless guy
uh who was started like yelling about
stuff
and
saliwa went over to him he wasn't miked
you know he just went over and started
talking to the guy and being like oh you
know talking to him like a human being
which obviously he is uh what's your
situation you know have you been are you
supposed to be taking medication have
you been hospitalized and the guy breaks
down
and says you know i don't want to be a
burden to anybody i don't you know i
don't want to to do this to everybody
ensley was like no you're you're not
like you're our responsibility
and then he asks him do you want to
stand here with us do you want to stand
here with us yeah now the current
administration de blasio de blasio's
wife shirlene mcrae tweets out like if
you see homeless people call the
homelessness outreach line you had uh
bloomberg saying you know previously
saying uh
if you see homeless people in need of
help you know don't help them yourself
call somebody and call the homelessness
outreach to go help them and i think
this is part of it too we don't take any
responsibility for our neighbors we
don't take any care for the people
around us we assume that there's always
somebody else who's supposed to do that
thing and that maybe we should let them
know hey
there's someone bleeding to death over
here i'm gonna be late for coffee you
know so i can't do it you deal with it
and we see that all over the place in
our culture where we are supposed to put
our trust in
the government we saw this with obama
and i think in a lot of ways this goes
back to obama like obama had this whole
um
like a video for obamacare right that
was this woman
and i think her name was julie in the
advertising and she was uh she was just
all by herself and at every turn the
government was there to help her right
down to at a certain point she had a
child and the government was there to
help her
she had a child there was still nobody
else in the picture at that point there
was still just her in the child there
was no one else that she could there was
no father right is my point bad
marketing it was weird marketing at the
time and i remember looking at it being
like i don't want to have a baby with
the government you know
i'm not up for that that's weird and
creepy and that's where we've landed i
was recently
again like facebook with people that
i've known for a long time or whatever
and there was a woman who was saying
that
someone in california had
come up with a lot of money for
homelessness housing and she found this
infuriating this was a private guy and
she was like you know why
why do we need this private guy to come
up with homelessness housing uh it's not
his responsibility the government should
be doing this and i was like no this guy
should be doing it if he thinks that
this is his responsibility to take care
of people then he should be doing it
obviously we can't just have a
government and say
everybody just rely on the government
and the government will come and
interfere in every aspect of our lives
we should want to take responsibility
for each other we should want to care
about our neighbors and be cared about
why do we not want that
there was an old woman who died next
door to me i had only met her two times
and i felt so uh stupid that i had you
know barely ever interacted with her and
then her son shows up to clear out her
apartment and he's like
do you want you knew my mother and i was
like dude i i met your mother twice like
please don't give me her valuable things
i don't you know
yeah i'll give it to you i have a
garbage who lives next door to her like
i never you know shout out to uh luke's
luke's video we mentioned before it's
called i think it's called like just
keep going you have nothing to lose
gronkowski from we are change and it's
this old video you made back like 10
years ago where he's like you know i
take the train every day in new york and
there's millions of people but i noticed
they never talked to each other so one
day i decided to start talking to these
people and then he films and asked them
questions that you know get kind of
weird like do you trust the government
but i think it's funny and it makes a
good you know emotional point anyway
that like people in new york city they
live around each other they're not
neighbors
neighbor is the wrong word that is
exactly the wrong word remember exactly
mr rogers
would say
hello neighbor
that meant something yeah now it's like
you're not my neighbor like you live
next to me and you yell too much yeah
i've actually started trying to like
talk to the people in my building now
ever since this woman died i was like
well that sucks uh and so i've tried to
talk to people and they just kind of
look at me but i'm gonna i think i'm
gonna keep it up but there's this um
there was a sign on the mta speaking of
not talking to each other on the mta
with kovid right so there were uh three
options and the mta let you know which
one was the appropriate option the first
option was to stick figures having a
conversation with no masks looking
animated having a conversation and it
said not this
the next one was people wearing masks
having a conversation and it said not
this and then the final one was two
people looking down separately at books
not looking at each other having no
communication at all and the mta was
like this this is what we want you to do
don't talk to anybody don't look at
anybody don't be near anybody don't
exist with other people just live in
your own literal bubble behind your face
covering
and go about your business
that's the brave new world we live in
yeah that's what happens when you let
the
corporations take over men whether it's
the city the state the the corporate
corporation the centralized authority
makes these stupid machine-like rules
and restrictions on humans when we're
not machines
i watch this movie it's called i think
it's called 2149 where it's like people
live in concrete pods their whole lives
and they just all they do is play video
games
and they interact without just by typing
and that's like the world that's the em
forester story also the machine stops
did you ever read that no no what's that
it's a free download in fact you can get
it because it's uh out of what do you
call it copyright the machine stops ian
forrester wrote this book 19
i don't know
1914 1918 i don't know when it was
something like that
and uh all of these people live
underground in their own little studio
apartments and whenever they need
anything they ask the machine for it and
the machine will provide it whether it's
food or anything else whenever they want
to talk to each other they all deliver
lectures on basically telescreens
and it's basically the internet and
that's how they talk to each other and
they respond 1909 1909 there you go yeah
interesting yeah this is a fascinating
story and so basically he predicted
people sit in their mom's basements yes
yes playing warcraft yeah and he
predicted online dating as well wow
because the main character this woman i
think her name's uh vashti or something
so she lives in her little underground
uh cubby she delivers lectures through
telescreen and most of her lectures most
of the things she delivers she talks
about our responses to other people's
lectures and it is at the beginning of
the story she talks about how she was
listening to a symphony and there was a
glitch in it and when she first
recognized that when she first heard the
symphony with the glitch she was very
upset and she was you know wanted to
complain about this glitch and now she
wouldn't recognize the symphony without
it
creepy it's very creepy and also she has
a child but she had a child with a man
who showed up
they
you know
engaged
had a child and he left and she never
saw him again
so it's it's tinder it's serious
everything it's amazon
and then of course the machine breaks
down and so all of the people eventually
they start like
pouring out of their cubbies and the
little transport system doesn't work
um
and her son who had contacted her makes
his way to the surface
to breathe air for the first time and
it's poison and it kills him and he dies
but he's
nice wow em forrester is amazing thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you